well uh when I went to the pen it was
2000
13. and I and I came down Sick off like
how old were you uh or how long ago or I
was 20 when I went to jail and I was 25
24 when I got out so you did four years
yeah in the state pen yeah [ __ ] what was
your if you don't mind me asking uh I
got charged with three attempted murders
and two armed robberies when I when I
first got arrested it was only one
attempt and one armed robbery and they
added two more attempts in the armed
robbery so I end up uh beating all the
attempted murders they end up finding
like camera footage from across the
street like six months after right that
that proved I didn't do [ __ ] when it
came to that so I ended up uh beating
the attempts and uh ended up getting one
arm armed robbery and I'm assuming that
wasn't your first time you ever got in
trouble with the law I got in trouble
for the same exact [ __ ] I had an open
case for that it's like the same exact
[ __ ] I had an open case for uh Robbie
before that when you were had you been
20 years old in La you might be over on
Sunset for [ __ ] shaking some pools
down as well
I don't know you know I don't know bro I
I just I feel like uh that
that really like helped get my mental
right more than anything like I just had
I had to do it in four years because I I
found a [ __ ] like it's in meditation
book it's like a [ __ ] Phil Jackson
book I swear to God I just picked it up
on the on the yard one day and I just
like I was into it that's why I got the
Buddha on my neck yeah The Omen [ __ ]
because I it just took me on like a
different place mentally you know what I
mean I was like man like this is what I
need like I need something to calm me
the [ __ ] down so
something about like the Zen like a
Buddhist right culture resonated with
you brought me in I needed it